avec l'actualité on trouve entourant le
groupe capital médias on a beaucoup
parlé de l'importance des journaux
régionaux ces dernières semaines mais
quoi de mieux pour s'en rendre compte
que de regarder quelques unes qui ont
marqué l'histoire on a fait l'exercice
avec le soleil le journal publié à
québec depuis plus d'un siècle et
mathieu donc vous avez sélectionné
quelques titres oui en fait c'est ma
collègue catherine lachaussée québec qui
qui a fait cette petite sélection de 10
vous pourrez d'ailleurs les consulter
sur notre site internet mais j'ai réduit
sa à 5 des questions autant mais les
plus marquantes mais ça ça balaye quand
même un siècle d'histoire la première
c'est la première une du soleil 1896 en
fait il faut savoir que le soleil
s'était de nouveau nom d'un autre
journal les lecteurs qui avait été
fondée par wilfrid laurier est
d'ailleurs cinq mois avant cette union
wilfrid laurier était devenu le premier
premier ministre francophone du canada
il ya un détail que vous remarquez
peut-être et qui n'est pas un détail
c'était l'organe du parti libéral le
soleil jusqu'en 1913 seconde guerre
mondiale ensuite enfin petit saut dans
le temps avec la conférence de québec et
cette photo meetic il ya reçu l
churchill mackenzie king et cette
réflexion qu'on se fait cette photo qui
est aussi puissante mais aujourd'hui il
est bien probable qu'elle prendrait
beaucoup plus de place à la une en fait
elles s'étalerait sur mon sur toute l'
us way et autres mamans marca mathieu ce
qu'on a appelé le samedi de la matraque
oui le samedi de la matraque on a encore
sur sur 7 à 7
cette conférence de québec très
important ce qui avait donné le prélude
au débarquement de normandie l'année
suivante le samedi de l'ama crâne la
matraque ça c'était à l'occasion d'une
visite de la reine elizabeth ii 1964
vieille de violentes émeutes 4000
policiers qui avaient été déployés dans
les rues ensuite une autre une qui un
peu triste parce que le sous titre de
cette une est un peu en forme d'épitaphe
québec n'a plus les moyens de son rêve
eh bien oui l'équipe des nordiques est
morte à l'âge de 23 ans l'espoir d'une
résurrection lui n'est pas encore
complètement mort
je termine avec celles ci ont parlé de
ces photos qui peuvent s'étaler parfois
complètement à travers toute la une
tous unis vous rappelez janvier 2016
deux mots qui suffisent pour dire la
solidarité avec notamment la communauté
musulmane après l attaque à la mosquée
de québec l'attentât une histoire donc
très riche histoire
heureusement qui se poursuit merci
mathieu